what do you identifies the big
challenges facing the sport you know
people talk about the future of Test
cricket how big an issue is that for you
well I think that it is without doubt
that the future of testicle is east
changing and there are a lot of factors
that have come into it and one is free
agency and franchise cricket the
spreading of the game of cricket across
borders they're not very familiar with
Test cricket nor have the heritage and
tradition of cricket to actually have
test with a take hold there have been
many changes made to try and hold on to
the current number of fans and
spectators that love the sport and also
to try and bring you bringing more and
more new fans through the sport to make
it financially viable not just for the
country that have iconic series like
England Australia after the powerhouses
of course like India but for the entire
test playing fraternity but do you fear
for the future of Test cricket well I
think the fears are justified and I
think maybe at certain times there will
have to be a change of mindset from
everyone concerned as to to what Test
cricket means the MCC me personally the
players and over 80% of the fans around
the world still hold Test cricket as as
the best format of the game and the most
important we've got to convert those
words that passion that love into actual
people at grounds and eyeballs on TV
Test cricket kind of encompasses
everything that is beautiful and great
about this sport there's no doubt about
it
for us as part of the MCC past players
present players administrators it is
imperative that we take the
responsibility seriously and we leave no
stone unturned in the future - to try
and not just safeguard the game but to
make it really relevant the people that
played so and to refit I mean how do you
prevent the franchise's in one day
cricket taking over the game and
effectively limited over Cricket white
bull cricket becomes the sport I think
we have to introduce cricket or give
kids as many opportunities as we
possibly can to get into cricket at an
early stage I think there's a hell of a
lot more that can be done in the
relationship between schools and clubs
MCC is playing an increasing number of
state schools in fact state school
fixtures now dominate amateur fixture
list and I think the key is to get
people playing early understanding the
pride that they have been following
either their county or their national
team but will they want to play one-day
cricket rather than test critizise Test
cricket the thing that we need to
preserve if we can introduce people to
the short form then hopefully they'll
get the opposite they'll enjoy it
they'll understand it and I want to
graduate to the ultimate form which is
Kumar says is is playing Test cricket
for your country corruption has been
identified as
and match-fixing how much of a threat do
you think that is I think it's a
constant threat especially with the
advent of so many franchise leagues
around the world so much money in the
game in terms of commercial in the
commercial sense it is the biggest
threat to the integrity of the sport the
trust that the fans and spectators have
in it when it comes to commercial terms
of marketing and sponsors you want to
watch something you love and Trust is
exactly I mean what you see is basically
it should be what you get and I think
there has to be greater play awareness
built around this and players themselves
taking responsibility to actually say no
first of all and to be educated as to
what the reporting process is and what
the protocols in place Trust needs to be
established between not just the ICC
anti-corruption needs but the home board
units that are in place at the same time
administrators being vetted selectors
quarters all of them need to buy into
this and to understand that if we do not
preserve the integrity of the game we
test cricket t20 cricket or any format
if the spectators don't trust it they're
not going to count they're not gonna
fall in love with it the passion dies
the game dies and the diversity in
cricket is also important how does the
MCC help get cricket into state schools
and increase the diversity in the game
twenty years ago we made a big move here
to admit women make them eligible for
membership that's been a huge success we
created a women's section and amatuer
window section which is flourish since
then two years ago we hosted the Women's
World Cup here which was one of the most
stunning days I can remember at Lord's
and that that needs to continue and
getting the sport played in state
schools
yeah well I'm taller scent of states
going to play the game yes well that's I
think where the relationship with clubs
can come work very very well MCC has
very good relationships with clubs as to
ECB and if we can encourage the clubs to
adopt schools where schools don't have
the facilities
schools can actually use the facilities
of the clubs it also works from terms of
the economics for the clubs because the
club's themselves are increasingly
threatened by pressures with you know
other sports and other distractions so I
think there's a lot lot more that can be
done and the answer doesn't purely live
at MCC it lies with cricket as a whole
the talent pool has to be of the whole
country not just limited to a privileged
part or a specific area and that is how
the game improves for public schools who
have facility to try and open that up to
state schools and and and and and and
other children around the world to come
in around England to come and use them
for the MCC to reach out to communities
as as we do very very well at the moment
and have a talent pathway growth and
participation pathway where hopefully
people will graduate see sometimes we
only think about national or
international representation but cricket
has a large bearing on how their life
progresses improvements in character
ideas about teamwork integrity playing
or doing something with passion and
following your dreams and not everyone
may make it to the international stage
or represent the county but I think that
the influence that will have in a
child's healthy upbringing in the
formative years of doing something
together and feeling part of a larger
group and having that benefit their own
word journey is huge and cannot be
underestimated beat cricket or any other
sport and cricket has values that
underpin it that you find very rarely
another sport and it is very relevant to
to life itself laws of cricket is an
area where the MCC does have real power
are there likely to be changes to the
law that we saw in the the World Cup
final when the overthrows and it hit the
bat and went for effectively 1 England
the World Cup are we going to see a
change to that law kuma there will be
definitely a revision to see whether
whether that needs to be changed the law
is it he you think it will be changed
well I think I think that I think there
will it will be looked at in the context
of that World Cup but the law in itself
in that situation is very clear
course that extra run could have been
avoided if the protocol was in place
that that decision could have been
referred to a third umpire use of
technology that has come so strongly
into the game as well so we like to run
this really look at whether it's the law
or whether we can influence the ICC to
try and have that protocol in place
whether radiation can be made